Speaker 1: . I have an unbelievable video to play
for you. A former national security adviser, John
Bolton, going on Newsmax and triggering Newsmax
host Eric BOLLING. Newsmax is furious with Bolton.
Bolton is not a good guy. And if anybody is
going to plan to write to me today and say,
David, you're rehabilitating John Bolton's image,
you are praising a war criminal, I am not praising
John Bolton. The thing about John Bolton is he's
a horrible war mongering, disgusting neocon who
rightly has assessed that Trump is a lunatic and
Trump is dangerous. And on that particular issue,
he happens to be correct. And the degree to
which he triggers Eric BOLLING is unbelievable.
John Bolton has been correctly saying we are
safer under Biden than under Trump. Doesn't
mean Bolton's a Democrat. Doesn't mean I
like. Bolton doesn't mean he's a good guy,
doesn't mean he wasn't one of the architects
of the Iraq war. It just means he has correctly
assessed that we are more safe under Biden than
Trump because Trump's completely unhinged. This so
triggered. Eric BOLLING You have to see this oral.
Speaker 2: Could you think that we're safer now
than we were under President Trump when he was
willing to put missiles into Syrian airbases
with Russians on the base? What's going on here,
sir? He didn't understand it because he didn't
understand fundamentally much of anything about
international affairs through his decisions were
not based on a coherent philosophy. Well.
Speaker 1: They weren't based on a coherent
foreign policy philosophy. They were based on
the philosophy of what can I do or say right
now that will benefit me. That that was that, too.
In that sense, Trump was adhering to a philosophy.
He often miscalculated, and it was a depraved
philosophy. But Bolton's essentially correct.
Speaker 2: Or coherent policy. We're
safer than we were. He told me he kept
under Donald Trump. He told world leaders
he signed a deal with the Taliban and kept
them on their back feet. They know where
he's coming from and that made us safe.
Speaker 1: There's a moment here
where Bolton Belly laughs at bawling
and that really sends Boeing into a tailspin.
Speaker 2: I mean, can you imagine? He had
president and he cut a deal with the
Taliban to withdraw from Afghanistan.
Did that make us safer when he was
banned from Afghanistan? Safer, right.
You know, it made us less safe is when Biden
pull us out of Afghanistan. 13 Americans died
and now there's Trump. Still no Taliban.
Speaker 1: Even so, even Bolton, Trump's
national security adviser, says what Biden did
in Afghanistan was the exact same thing Trump was
going to do. You're hearing it from the horse's
mouth and the Trump is still denied. They go, No,
it would have gone so smoothly
if it had been Trump overseeing
that withdrawal. No, it wouldn't have.
Speaker 2: Well, says back off. Don't
kill me. Right. Are you out of your
mind? Same thing they would have done
under Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Sir,
are you out of your mind? With respect, of course.
Speaker 2: No, I'll cook. Who cut the deal, Eric?
Who cut the deal? Who delivered it?
Donald Trump. Cut the deal. No, no,
no. Trump wanted. What would Trump have done? He
would probably have been a real member, sir. Let's
know. He did not. He absolutely did not.
He did. You don't know what you're talking
about. That's everybody out of a deal to do
exactly that disagrees with you. We don't know
what we're talking about. Trump said leave 2500
down until we have a smooth transition. But hey,
look, he said that after he cut the deal, the deal
cut us down to zero. That's what Trump wanted.
He wanted everybody out. The record on that is
completely clear. Over time, Biden pulled them
out. Well, now they're back at the gate. Eric,
have you ever read the deal? Stop. I know you got
to go before you were embarrassed even further.
Speaker 1: Okay, so, listen, I really don't like
John Bolton, but that was very good. It really
takes some skill to make Bolton seem like the
rational one in the room or the rational one in
the conversation. And again, don't write to me
that I'm praising Bolton. Bolton is a warmongering
neoconservative hack, but he specifically
pressed some important points. Number one, what
Biden did was the deal Trump made. And number two,
it wouldn't have gone any differently if it had
been Trump doing the out. And yes, of course,
we are, generally speaking, safer under Joe Biden
merely because Joe Biden is a steadier hand. And
the best part is Bolton just laughing at him and
saying, you don't know what you're talking about,
sending BOLLING off completely off the rails. At
least there are people willing to say this who are
from the former MAGA camp. And, you know, when
it comes to Bolton, did he know that Trump was
a lunatic all along? But he was so hungry for
the power of being national security adviser
that he looked the other way. Did he believe
Trump was rational but then had an awakening?
I don't even care. I think all of these people,
they're terrible people. Whatever brought them to
this point, it doesn't even really matter. But
anything that can pierce the echo echo chamber
of a platform as weaponized as Newsmax. I
think we generally speaking, need to welcome